almost missed that step
over sharing okay good afternoon
everybody
I just have a few things at the top so
once again please bear with me
President Biden has done more than any
prior president to tackle the climate
crisis and today he's making clear that
he's not done yet
in the Rose Garden this afternoon with
environmental justice leaders and
climate Advocates President Biden will
sign an executive order making
environmental justice part of the DNA of
every Federal agency his order will mean
cleaner air and water
reduce risk of asthma and cancer and
better access to safe and affordable
housing and clean transportation for
communities across the country the
president's bold climate and
environmental justice agenda could not
stand in Starker contrast to the
dangerous proposals Mega House
Republicans are putting forward as you
can see from the slide behind me
here you go while President Biden is
fighting to clean up toxic pollution and
lower costs through clean energy tax
credit
speaker McCarthy unveiled a ransom note
holding our economy hostage it's a 320
page plan to kill jobs fill our cities
with Smog and give asthma to our
children
The Proposal would repeal the inflation
reduction acts green energy tax credits
sending thousands of jobs back to China
it would make it easier for oil
companies to use toxic chemicals that
cause severe burns damage people's eyes
and quite literally melt bones
it would severely weaken the Clean Air
Act sending us back to the times when
cities across the country filled with
heavy smog that dirties are air and
poisons the lungs of our children
it's no surprise that over a dozen
health and medical organizations
including the American Lung Association
and the children's Environmental Health
Network oppose these dangerous proposals
speaker McCarthy extreme Mega proposals
would be a climate and health disaster
that President abide won't allow on his
watch
speaking of speaking of earlier this
week speaking McCarthy redoubled his
threat to default and hold the American
Kami hostage unless he can slash
programs of the American people
including our nation's veterans rely on
every single day while the president's
budget honors our country's sacred
obligation for care for America's
veterans their families caregivers and
survivors speaker McCarthy's proposal
would cut these critical programs by 22
percent and threaten critical services
for veterans today the Department of
Veterans Affair has put out analysis of
the impact speaker McCarthy's 22 percent
Cuts would have on those who have
bravely served our nation the extreme
Mega Cuts he has put forward would
mean 30 million fewer veteran outpatient
visits meaning veterans who need cancer
screenings or mental health services
would be unable to get an appointment
eliminate 50 000 veterans housing
vouchers putting veterans at greater
risk of homelessness
take away vital food assistance from
older veterans the va's ability to care
for the final resting place of veterans
who lost their life serving this country
the Congressional Republican plan is to
threaten veterans Health Food housing
and even grave sites for brinksmanship
over the debt ceiling
speaker McCarthy and House Republicans
should take those threats off the table
just as they did three times in the last
Administration now changing gears just a
bit as we move on I also want to take a
moment to wish the millions of Muslim
Americans across the country a blessed
and happy Eid Mubarak this is a special
day when many gather with family and
friends cherish those special bonds
celebrate a month of Charity and
spiritual reflection and rejoice over
the morning cup of coffee they longed
for the last 30 days
here in the Biden Administration for the
first time ever we've got over 100
Muslim American appointees joining in
the celebration these are public
servants who are tackling the climate
crisis building on the economy from the
bottom up in the middle out protecting
health
combating hate in all its forms
restoring our alliances and so much more
it's a testament to the commitment that
the president ran on to unite the nation
an Administration that reflects the
diversity of this nation the beauty of
this nation is a core part of that and
it helps ensure that our government
truly truly serves all Americans the
president of first lady looked forward
to continuing the tradition of hosting
the Eid celebration here at the White
House on May 1st now and now for the
week ahead a couple of things on Sunday
the president and the first lady will
return to the White House from Camp
David on Monday the president of first
lady and the U.S Secretary of Education
Miguel Cardona will honor the Council of
Chief State School officers 2023
teachers of the year at the White House
teachers from each state and territory
will be honored for their excellence in
teaching and commitment to students
learning later the president will
welcome Tennessee state representative
just just Justin Jones Justin Pearson
and Gloria Johnson to the White House
they will continue their discussion on
their efforts to ban assault weapons and
stand for the four democratic values on
Tuesday the president will deliver
remarks at the North American Building
trade unions legislative Conference held
at the Washington Hilton the president
will discuss how this investing and how
how his investing in America agenda is
bringing manufacturing jobs back or
manufacturing more broadly back
rebuilding the middle class creating
good paying jobs and union jobs
on Wednesday the president and the first
lady will host president president Yoon
Pardon Me and Mrs Kim for a state visit
to the United States which would include
a state dinner as part of the visit the
president and the first lady will
participate in a visit with President
Moon and Mrs Kim to the Korean War
Memorial on Tuesday evening on Wednesday
morning the president and the first lady
the the vice president and the second
gentleman will greet president oon and
Mrs Kim for the official arrival
ceremony on Wednesday morning then the
president will hold a bilateral meeting
with president oon in the afternoon the
president will host a joint press
conference with president oon in the
evening the president and the first lady
will greet president oon and Mrs Kim on
a right on arrival for the state dinner
after the president and the first lady
will participate in a photo opportunity
with president oon and Princess Kim at
the grand staircase on the occasion of
the state dinner then the president and
the first lady will host president oon
and Mrs Kim for a state dinner
as you may have seen this morning
korean-american chef Edward Lee will be
the guest Chef for the state dinner he
was selected by the first lady because
of his experience with the intersection
of American Cuisine with Korean
influence for entertainment guests will
enjoy musical selection by Broadway
Stars Norm Lewis
Lee Leah solinger and Jessica bosk on
Friday the president will present the
commander-in-chief's trophy to the Air
Force Falcons during a ceremony at the
White House on Saturday the president
and the first lady the vice president
and the second gentleman will attend the
White House correspondence association
dinner at the Washington Hilton where
the president will also deliver remarks
now finally
uh I just want to say one last thing and
I know there's a lot of interest in this
obviously I totally understand this a
lot of questions about all all of this
the the Press reports that we have seen
the last 24 hours when it comes to the
president's plans for 2024
I just want to say and I know all of you
in this room know this I I understand
that you all know this but there might
be some folks who are watching at home
who may not know
um and so just want to lay this out for
all of them as a government employee
federal law prohibits me from discussing
campaign related topics from this Podium
so I will be following that law and not
discussing anything regarding the 2024
race the president has been very clear I
know you all have reported this many
times and he has said this in many
multiple interviews over the past
several months with multiple outlets and
on his attentions to to uh to what his
attentions are and when it comes to 2024
but beyond that I will not be able to
comment on anything again related to the
2024 elections and with that and thank
you so much for your patience with me
today with our Toppers with that Darlene
please take us away thank you I wanted
to follow up housekeeping question on
your topper the Tennessee lawmakers when
they come on Monday
do you expect that to be an open Event
uh with the president and those
lawmakers or
what can you what can you tell us about
what that visit will look like so first
we'll have more to share but I do want
to say that the president looks very
much looks forward to meeting with the
three legislators who as you know he
spoke with had a very uh important
critical we thought conversation with
them about how to move forward with gun
reform about them doing their Democratic
Duty and and
peacefully protesting for uh assault
weapons ban and what we saw and what we
saw happen to the three of them as you
heard the president say as you have
heard me say it was undemocratic when
they were expelled and essentially
ousted out of their out of their seats
and it was also an attack on our
democracy and so what you'll see is uh
the president sitting down with the with
these three legislators having a
conversation on how to move forward on
how to move forward with common sense
gun reform how to move forward on
protecting our communities our kids our
churches and he will hear them out and
he looks forward to having that
conversation and we'll have more on what
that will look like and if there will be
any availability for all of you to uh to
uh to kind of experience or see that
that meeting I just don't have anything
at this time
today and I wanted to follow up on
something that John Kirby said when he
was here yesterday and also this morning
in his virtual handle which is that
Americans should have no expectation of
a U.S government coordinated evacuation
at this time and we expect that's going
to remain the case now obviously the US
government has warned Americans about
the security situation in Sudan but can
you explain why this is the government's
position like shouldn't Americans abroad
expect some help from their government
getting out of a trouble spot totally
hear your question and just to be clear
like
Americans in Sudan have been warned
since this past since this since last
year and it's been a level four the
state department as you know they tend
to give the warnings to Americans abroad
on what's happening on the situation and
so it is not our standard procedure to
evacuate evacuate American citizens
living abroad
Afghanistan was a unique situation for
many reasons including already hosting a
significant military presence and ending
a 20-year conflict the Afghanistan
evacuation was not was not the norm as
you all know and many of you have
reported that so for example in Libya
Yemen and Syria we do not provide
large-scale evacuations for American
citizens and lprs even as those
government collapsed instead we urged
Americans to use commercial options to
leave the country while those options
were still readily available we also
offered financial assistance to those
who needed help departing the country in
accordance with our standard counselor
services for American citizens in these
sorts of extraordinary situations but
again it is not our standard procedure
and the state department does its best
to provide information to citizens who
are abroad and and giving them the
warning when necessary and this is
something that when it comes to Sudan
this is a warning a level four warning
that we provided to them many months ago
basically
um telling Americans who were there to
leave if they could and also not to
travel Americans not to travel to Sudan
so we've been very clear on that again
it's not our standard procedure thank
you
um you mentioned speaker McCarthy's
proposals and I know you discussed this
yesterday but I just want to make sure
that I'm clear on your position the
president is not going to sit down with
the speaker until he agrees to a clean
plan to raise the debt limit so we have
been very clear that the speaker uh
without uh without delay should put
forth a clean bill on the on the floor
uh to uh to avoid default we have been
very clear about that and that stance
that stance continues we are we are
always happy to have a conversation
about the budget we've been very clear
about that about the spending that they
propose we already have a sense of what
they value with their 22 percent uh
spending cuts as I mentioned veterans
when it comes to Veterans education
wheels wheels on Meals on Wheels and a
host of extensive other programs that
will really hurt Americans and Americans
really rely on these programs to make
their ends meet and so we've we're going
to continue to analyze that and we'll
have more to share but clearly as as I
laid out at the top we are clearly doing
a deep dive on these different programs
but we need to see them put this uh uh
raise raise the debt ceiling avoid uh
avoid a default and not put our economy
or take our the American economy hostage
and we've been very clear about that
trying to get a sense of what you need
to see to have this conversation between
the president and the speaker because
you've said you're happy to talk about
the budget the president or the speaker
has now put out what appears to be the
closest thing he's going to get to
putting out a budget so what are you
waiting for
so what we're waiting for is for them to
avoid default what we're waiting for
them for House Republicans is to put
that on the floor so that they could we
can avoid the fault that's what we want
sensation until they put out there we've
been very clear about that we do not
want to negotiate on this we want to
make sure that they do what they did the
last three times and avoid default they
need to put that bill put a clean bill
on the floor so that we do not continue
they do not continue to hold the
American economy hostage and that's what
they're doing which has will have
dangerous consequences for not just our
economy for the American people so
that's what we want them to do
look they need to do that and then we
can go ahead and have a conversation
about the budget and just one quick once
as you did the week ahead does the
president have any plans to Mark the
fourth anniversary of his announcement
of his 2020 campaign
that is very good
I had to try
um I don't have anything else beyond the
week ahead that I just laid up but I
really appreciate the effort that was
very good
yeah
will address questions about 2024. oh
well you know
don't have anything to say about 2024
either way it's not going to come from
here from this Podium as I have stated
and so I'm just going to leave it there
and has the president now ordered the
evacuation of American diplomatic
Personnel from Sudan what's the status
of that so I know that the Admiral took
some questions on this earlier and so
when it comes to the the diplomats and
the embassy we have uh as you all know
and you've heard me say this we have no
higher priority than the safety of our
U.S government personnel and their
families overseas and we have made very
clear to both sides that any attacks
threats or dangers
opposed to our diplomats are totally
unacceptable as you heard from the
Department of Defense U.S Africa command
is monitoring the situation and
conducting prudent planning for various
contingencies as part of this planning
the U.S is deploying additional
capabilities to the region for
contingency purposes related to securing
and potentially
facilating departure of U.S embassy
personnel from Sudan if circumstances
require it so uh any other questions we
would refer you to the state department
but I just laid out what the Department
of Defense and U.S Africa command uh is
is monitoring and and putting into place
just in case okay I have a question
about the actual Hatch Act in the past
uh presidents when they're preparing to
run for reelection I've tried to
separate their job as president from the
job as candidate for example they'll
commit to only holding political
meetings in their residence only phoning
donors from the residents and in fact I
think there is a special phone line on
Air Force One when President Obama was
in office to talk to donors is President
Biden going to take similar steps I
don't have anything to share on on
anything that's related to 2024. okay
and um I can't give David this weekend
what's what is the president planning to
do always up there do you have a list of
steps I do not have a list of Staff
that's attending um well I think usually
when he leaves we put out a little pool
note on who's traveling so you'll have
that you all will have that so that is a
common practice but I don't have
anything specific to uh to lay out when
he's at cam David you know that's kind
of private time with his family I just
don't have anything more family time
he's not expected I'm family with the
first lady or with whomever else is is
with him I just don't have any specifics
with him for it to share okay Nancy
thanks green can you give us some
details on what the White House is doing
to try to win over this group of
moderate Senate Democrats
Senate Senator tester Senator Cinema
Senator Kelly senator manchin who are
still on the fence about the labor
secretary nominee Julie Sue so look uh
we have a complete confidence in Julie
Julie Sue's nomination and for her to be
confirmed that is something that we are
confident about it I think I've said
this many times before at least a couple
times at this Podium this past week that
when she was deputy secretary going for
deputy secretary for her confirmation
she got all all Democratic senators to
uh to vote for her and to make for a
confirmation and so we expect that the
office of ledge Affairs and other folks
here are in constant communication on
all of our nominees on this partic on
their confirmation process and procedure
again we're very confident and we're
going to continue to have those
conversations with those Democratic
senators I just don't have anything
further to share on that is the
president himself getting involved in
the effort to seal this domination I
don't have any calls to preview but this
is indeed a priority for this President
and will continue to be a priority Julie
Sue's confirmation uh again we have
confidence that we will get her through
and we'll continue to have those
conversations with them those Democratic
senators and others not just Democratic
senators but also Republican Senators as
well
draw their nomination lately there was
the FAA administrator there was the FCC
commissioner those nominations held out
there for months and months and then had
to you know basically the White House
had to go back to square one is the
White House doing enough to run these
nominations by moderate seven Democrats
ahead of time to make sure that they're
on board we have we're having regular
conversations with uh Democratic
senators and Republicans as well to to
shore up support for our nominees that
is something that is important we
understand how this process work if
anything this is a president that
understands how the process works in the
Senate when it comes to confirmation
when it comes to putting forth here at
nominees when it comes to what you need
to do to get support short that support
for uh for that that particular nominee
so that is not unusual you you're
speaking uh you're speaking about an
admission Administration or you're
looking at an Administration that is uh
well very well versed in experienced in
that process so we'll continue to have
those conversations we've also so had a
lot of nominees that have made it
through and so look we're going to be
we're going to be optimistic about this
we're going to continue to have continue
to do that Outreach to Senators on the
hill we thank Julie Sue is is uh is the
right person for this job as you know
she's she worked alongside the former
labor secretary and they were part of
creating record jobs right that we've
seen in the first two years of this
Administration two more than 2.5 million
jobs and so we are going to do the work
to get her through
thanks Karine uh New York city mayor
Eric Adams said he was visiting the
White House today to meet with White
House officials he's been vocal and
wanting more support from the
administration on migrants who've been
transported to New York City do you know
if that came up in his meetings or any
more details about what he was here for
today so I don't have uh details on what
came up in the meetings I could tell you
that he met with our chief of staff Jeff
science he also met with Julie Rodriguez
today and he is going to be having a
meeting if it hasn't occurred yet with
secretary yellin this afternoon and as
you know it coincides with the meeting
of Mayors here at the White House at
followed by a meeting with FEMA
administrator so he is going to be FEMA
administrator Chief of Staff Julie
Rodriguez secretary yellin so he has a
host of meetings with certain members of
the President's White House and
administration just don't have anything
further to read out and I'm sure there
are a range of issues will come up and
and he is a partner on many issues that
are important to this President they
have another one that's a bit off the
beaten path on the uh the Washington
Commander sale
you do have a role here so let me lay it
out oh my goodness the team has long one
it's a new stadium at the RFK site which
is on federally owned land but there's
been an obstacle to for that to happen
because of the Scandal plague ownership
of Daniel Snyder so now that that is
coming to a close is the White House
supportive of transferring that land to
the city to open the door for a new
state so I honestly I would have to take
that back to uh to the team I was not
tracking tracking of the use of federal
land
um so I would have to try to get back
with the team and get an answer to you
all right thanks yeah um can you say
what this environmental justice
mean if anything for the people in East
Palestine Ohio oh that's a very good
question
um look I think what's important to note
about this environmental justice EO is
the president's continued support in his
climate agenda his ambitious climate
agenda he has the the most ambitious
climate agenda than any other president
in history and I one way that you can
look at this today is that he's
continuing to deliver on that ambitious
agenda and he's not done yet right this
is a continuing continuation of what
he's promised the American people again
when the president walked into the
administration climate climate change
was one of the crises that he felt that
he needed to deal with so he'll be
standing together as I mentioned with
environmental justice leaders climate
Advocates and Community leaders and he's
going to sign a new executive order
making environmental justice the mission
of every Federal agency when you think
about that being the DNA of of the
administration I think that's an
important important piece here and so
again this is just delivering again on
his uh on how he sees moving forward
with dealing with climate change his
promise that he made in 2020 and as he
continues to deliver throughout his uh
his tenure here and so that is that is
going to be our Focus what he's going to
continue to do more work to make sure
that we deal with an issue that's
incredibly important
additionally we're I think everyone is
watching the Supreme Court to see what
they do on Mr Kristen
um is the President also watching and is
there a scenario under which he would he
would make public remarks about the
decision and and under What scenario
would he so look we are all watching as
all of you this is an unprecedented time
when it comes to Memphis Stone uh a as
I've mentioned before it is a drug
that's been around for more than 20
years that's been used in in six more
than 60 countries it is a it is a it is
has been approved by the FDA which is an
evident evidence-based approval and we
should not forget that alongside of a
wide range of other uh of other
prescription drugs that FDA get has the
right to approve again an independent
agency all I can tell you at this time
is we're all waiting we're all watching
is that we we are prepared we are
prepared for whatever announcement comes
out of the Supreme Court and uh and if
if need be we are prepared also for a
long legal battle that is our commitment
and our promise to the millions of women
across the country the president has
been very clear this Administration has
been very clear we are going to continue
to fight for women's women's
Reproductive Rights
likely to see the president speak on
this I just don't have anything to share
we're waiting to see uh What uh what
what the announcement's going to be what
the outcome of the Supreme Court
decision will be and so I don't want to
get ahead of that I just don't have
anything to share for this weekend and
yeah
go ahead thank you Katie I'd like to ask
you about a report from earlier this
week about Canada informing NATO
officials that it will never meet it's
the alliance two percent uh defense
Target as a president is the president
worried for the security in the Arctic
in the reality where Canada obviously
cannot uh
develop its obligation so let me first
say that United States and Canada have a
close uh defense partnership you saw you
saw the two the two leaders together
just recently in Canada so we're
committed Partners uh in NORAD the only
by by National military command in the
world and we're closely and we're
closely working together to meet the
threats and challenges that we face and
so during that meeting in Canada between
the two leaders in Ottawa just last
month both leaders committed to invest
in the modernization of NORAD including
enhanced domain awareness in the Arctic
to protect our citizens and Sovereign
territory The Joint statement that was
released with Canada during the visit
contained a number of specific
Investments Canada is making in its
defense infrastructure so certainly I
would point you to that joint statement
the two leaders also underscored the
importance of investment in modern ready
and capable forces under the 2014 Wales
Summit Defense investment pledge in the
face of global threats so again they
have a close defense partnership and
they are both committed
president
of a strong Canadian involvement in
Haiti to bring some sort of stability to
take a more active role to bring some
sort of stability so look as you know
that conversation came up during during
the meeting as well this is a this is
something that the president addressed
as well in Ottawa when he when they did
their at their conference we've made it
clear that we believe the security and
humanitarian situation in Haiti is
worsening in the situation on the ground
will not improve without armed security
assistance from International partners
and any decisions about that about any
type of military force would be done in
consultation with the UN with the
Haitian government and those discussions
are still going on I just don't have
anything else to add as you know the
United States has been a strong a strong
supporter of making sure and providing
assistance to to the Haitian people and
so we'll continue continue to do that
um when it comes to Tennessee lawmakers
and the possibility I'm hearing this
strong possibility of a special session
in May that could deal with Firearms Etc
what would be the president's hope if
they go back into special session to
discuss this very passionate issue not
just in Tennessee but around the around
the nation do you think Tennessee now
would possibly lead if they do change so
we've seen yesterday I laid out a few
States Washington State and Michigan I
believe if I'm if I'm remembering the
states correctly who are leading who are
leading and making sure that we're
moving forward with protecting our
communities protecting our schools and
uh making sure that we're dealing with
this epidemic of gun violence that we're
seeing across the country and they're
taking leadership and so that is
something that we certainly welcome that
is something that we want to see from
State houses from state governments to
to make sure that we're doing everything
that we can to protect our kids to
protect our communities and so of course
the president would welcome any efforts
to come for state legislators to come
together with common sense gun laws to
come together to ban assault weapons
what we have been calling for so that is
something certainly that we're for what
we've been calling for is for congress
the legislative branch of the federal
government to take action as well for
Republicans to come together with
Democrats to take action and so the
president is going to continue to use
the bulby Pulpit to do just that because
we also need to see action from the
other side of Pennsylvania Avenue so
that's what we've been calling for in a
very uh at a very consistent way over
this past year
waiting for congress Tennessee the state
that has some of the weakest gun laws in
the nation for gun manufacturers in the
state and it's very passionate do you
believe that if Tennessee does change
anything
when it comes to guns after Covenant
School deadly shooting do you believe
though for the states that are holding
up it could make a difference States
yeah I think so yeah I think any state
leadership on this issue on gun violence
on dealing with this epidemic on moving
forward and protecting communities I
think is important yesterday I laid out
I talked about a few States who were
doing just that and we lifted them up
because it was important for the
American people and for I know you all
cover this uh for us from for for us to
say it from the podium and to list out
the other states that are actually
taking action and so yes of course if
Tennessee were to take action and move
forward and again dealing with a gun
reform in a real way that's going to
protect and save lives of course we
would commend that
the president will be the second sitting
president of Hiroshima
when he goes to Japan I know when Obama
went there was a lot of pressure from
some Quarters on him to apologize for
the uh you know for dropping the atomic
bomb is that something the president's
going to talk about when he's there I'm
just not going to get ahead of what
we're going to be doing uh next month
we'll have more to share when we get
closer to uh to the dates but I just
don't have anything to share at this
time quick one to come uh it's not a
2024 on a hatchback type question let's
put it that way that's what you think
my channel I love how you setting it up
I'm getting that out the way first but
you know but Donald Trump is the front
runner uh at the moment clear
front-runner Republican party is he is
he wants to be president and he's the
front runner of this party
uh this is somebody the President Biden
is described as you know a danger
literally a dangerous country and this
movement an existential threat to
democracy Etc so candidate or not is
President current President Biden is he
is is he following the words and actions
of Donald Trump on a fairly regular
basis considering he's a danger in his
view so look
um appreciate the question Sebastian uh
as you just laid out yourself he is a
candidate for 2024 and you're
specifically talking about a result or
or what could potentially happening in
that happen in that race and I'm just
not going to speak to it what I can
speak to is how the president is
focusing on the American people and
delivering for their American people
here's what we know to be a threat uh
what we know to be a threat is the Maga
wing of the Republican party and speaker
McCarthy who are put forward a uh you
know a plan a blueprint that's holding
the American economy hostage that's a
threat that's a threat to the our
economy that's a threat to Americans
across the country we think about the 22
spending cut that they put forward
that's a threat to Veterans that's a
threat to our education
and that's a threat to the American
people who need these different programs
to make ends meet and so that's what
we're going to focus on right now that's
what feel free to ask me a million
questions about that and I'll do my best
to answer them and so on the president
uh when he makes his decision he'll make
this decision it will not come from here
I will not be talking about 2024. I made
that very clear as a government
officials not something that I can do
from here but I'm happy to talk about
how we're delivering here at the White
House for the American people
oh boy
oh okay all right Michael why have you
been willing to talk about President
Trump before
it was done in the administration no I
know I'm just I'm answering your
question because I'm saying the
president Trump we were talking about
what he did in the last Administration
we're talking about policies that were
harmful in the past administration no no
he asked me does the president still
believe that uh that uh Donald Trump is
a threat if he wins right because he's
going to be he's a candidate that's
something different
I was asking is the president is
President Biden does he follow the words
and actions of this person yes Trump as
a candidate right as a candidate so yes
I'm not I'm not no I'm saying I'm not
talking about 2024. I'm not talking
about 20. what I have talked about what
I have talked about Donald Trump has
been a candidate for re-election or for
a lecture however you want to call it I
I understand that a year talk but you I
mean you've talked about him a lot yes
but he's done a lot and he and so as as
I talked about his policies when he was
president that's what I have talked
about that's what I've talked about
we've talked about immigration his
immigration policies right we talked
about how he separated uh babies from
their parents we've talked about that
and how uh how those policies were
incredibly dangerous when he was
president that's what I have talked
about I've not talked about him as a
candidate and I'm not going to do that
from here I'm just not I'm not going to
talk about the polling I'm not going to
talk about what 2024 is going to look
like I'm not going to talk about that
from here okay
um
this morning from Bloomberg that um the
G7 countries including the US are
considering a near-total ban on exports
to Russia I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about that idea
whether it's one that the administration
is embracing pushing
yeah so we're we're gonna we're
committed to holding Russia accountable
that's something that we're committed to
doing here and in coordination with our
G7 Partners have put in place the
largest set of sanctions and Export
control actions ever imposed on a major
economy uh these actions have had a
significant impact undercutting to
Russia's ability to find and fight its
unjust War uh don't have any new
measures to announce today at this time
but you can see from many of the RG G7
statements that we are committed to
continuing to hold Russia accountable
and supporting Ukraine as long as it
takes and that's going to continue to be
our commitment
um yesterday secretary-in-law work has
said that the administration uh next
week will announce for new border
security policy and anticipation of the
surge in migrants into May so I'm
wondering what you can tell us about
that what we can expect and specifically
uh does the administration plan to
resume the Detention of parents and
children who crossed the border as a
together as a family so the state
department and the Department of
Homeland Security will have more to
share on this soon uh so don't have
timing on that or detail to to provide
at this time as you know earlier this
year back in January the Department of
Homeland Security did put forth what
their continuing implementation plan was
going to be and they announced it again
earlier this year and the way that we
see it as the plan is working we see the
data of making sure unlawful immigration
goes down and again we've seen that in
the numbers but as far as uh any uh any
plans future plans that should be
outside
the Detention of families is that
something that is on the table again
they'll have more to share later on I
just don't have anything to announce at
this time good Karen thanks you had
talked earlier this week about the
president's call to Ralph you're always
family as the president reached out to
any of the other families or victims of
some of these shootings happened
recently for the seemingly innocent
mistakes that they have made yes so the
president as you mentioned uh called RAF
yarl and spoke to him directly spoke to
his uh to his mother and they had a uh a
good conversation talked and talked
about uh how uh his success in school
and talked about uh the president re
um recommitted to him uh how his focus
is going to be on a really truly
continuing to deal with gun violence
don't have any other calls to read out
at this time the president as you know
has talked to multiple families sadly in
the last two years who have been who
have been victims to these gun gun gun
violence tragedies and so that that's
something that is easy to do and
certainly has visited communities over
the past two years that have been struck
by these by this type of violence I just
don't have any other conversations to
lay out I just kind of with this string
of these examples this week of you know
pulling into the wrong driveway of
basketball rolling into the yard what
does the president make of this so these
reactions by people that they have gone
and shot people for something that is
innocent just a wrong mistake what does
he make of that that was what people did
look the president thinks that it's time
that we uh that uh that Congress
republicans in Congress take action on
these types of gun violence that we're
seeing in our communities in our school
that doesn't change it that doesn't
change the president continuing to use
his bully pulpit to call uh to call out
Congress or or really call Congress to
take action and that's what we need to
see we need to see Common Sense gun laws
and we need Congress to legislate the
president has taken
more than two dozen executive action on
this issue on this gun violence to deal
with gun violence epidemic and now we
need to see Congress take action we need
Republicans to step in we need
Republicans to show some courage in
Congress and we're just not seeing that
at this time and it is important to do
that to save lives across the country
and I'll leave it at that I'll see you
guys on Monday thanks everybody